jason hayward was a healthy scratch
tonight he spoke with david ross
he decided not to play reports are if
he's
fully supported his teammates playing
this game they supported his decision to
sit out
here's a chance trying to take advantage
of the lead-off walk
and then the one-out single
rizzo fairball
one run in
half to third it's one to nothing he's
able to get on top of that elevated
fastball from fulmer you see candelario
sliding off the bag and didn't have time
to react and get back and knock that
ball down
so run scoring hit for anthony and the
batter is baez
baez with a liner that's going to be
caught here comes the throw to the plate
two nothing sac flies half
scores maven sprays one to right and
that's gonna get over the head and off
against the wall
bonifacio will hold up maven has his
second hit of the night it's a double
and the tigers got something cooking
here in the fourth got to cash in with
austin romine who's singled to right his
last time up
muscles this one it's going to bloop
that will drop bonifacio trots home
tigers on the board maven moves up to
third
romine has his second hit of the night
it's an rbi single 2-1 chicago john
lester five-time all-star three-time
world series champion he got clobbered
by the white sox his last timeout
allowing eight runs and a career-high
four home runs against chicago
swing and a miss he struck him out
fly ball to right playable for half john
lester on this hot night worked five
strong inning innings right-hander joe
jimenez
by far the earliest
he has appeared in a game mostly in the
ninth
so far this season schwarber a fly ball
in the corner
gone a home run
three to one
everything he's hit tonight has been to
the opposite field and that one left the
yard yeah a little breathing room as uh
schwarber unloads on the very first
pitch he sees from jimenez tigers trying
to bounce right back here in the sixth
cent to right
back goes hap and that's going to be off
the wall
maven will score austin romine at his
third hit of the night
and his second rbi
what a battle won by romine in that
personal war with wick
it's a 3-2 cubbies lead that's a
fastball
and he just
barrels it up hap wasn't able to get
over there then he takes a nice ricochet
back towards home plate
no problem for cameron maven to
score and now a huge spot for detroit
as he faces ryan tupera who is
eight straight of scoreless innings
pitched
right back up the middle perfect tie
ball game
scope wears a crown again it's three-all
barrel it up and driving it right past
capura up the middle
everyday scope huh and here's cabrera on
the ground in the hole it gets under the
glove of baez and the inning stays alive
thanks to miguel cabrera's second hit of
the night sets up a clutch situation for
jamer candelario maybe jamer can get it
done right here one one two right
that will drop and it will skip by the
right fielder half
scope will score cabrera to third
candelario into second the tigers have
the lead
hap has to go for it and he didn't play
it well here's nico goodrum he's the
eighth batter of the inning for detroit
drives one to right center field that's
going to be down two more runs home for
the tigers good room is getting greedy
trots in with a stand-up double the
tigers
open up the lead to 6-3
so charged with two tupera
who've been so good he had allowed a
three total in his first 10 appearances
combined
swing and a miss finally it's over
10 batters come to the plate half of
them score big offensive knight that's
for sure
look at that box score it's crowded the
17 hits the most detroit has had in a
game this year here's the o2 to cabrera
punch to right
and hap lets it get by him
another run scores for the tigers
victor reyes crosses home plate it's 7-3
detroit miguel finds another hole for
his third hit of the game he's been on
base four times picks up an rbi came
down to a battle of the bullpens and so
far the tigers have won the battle bodhi
and that will
be right at the wall for
bodhi it's a lead-off double horner has
been perfect tonight two knocks and a
walk
yeah it's all about base runners well
that'll work
he'll knock in a run to make it seven to
four
this game's not over yet nobody out
fair ball
horner to third
he's coming around he will score it's a
two-run game and the tying run will come
up with nobody out cubs have the tying
run at first base with nobody out here
in the night rizzo in the air to center
it's deep
and it is going to be caught by reyes a
run will score
[Music]
that was kind of a circuitous route by
reyes but he made a nice catch
[Music]
it's a one-run game it's up to schwarber
here comes the 1-0
right back to farmer and he's got it oh
boy little touch and go in the ninth for
buck farmer and the tigers but they hold
on
and win the series over the cubs
7-6 the final